Oh, now you've gone and done it. You've
clicked on this video, and now you're
about to learn a hack that's going to
allow you to jam the blues in any
[music] key, anytime, anywhere, and it
only takes two notes. And when you start
applying this hack I'm about to show
you, you're going to be well equipped to
handle any blues situation, [music]
whether you're playing with a buddy or
hitting the stage at your local blues
jam. All right, so let's get into it.
So, what is this twotee blues hack I'm
talking about? Basically, this is just
going to be a two note grouping that
you're going to be able to use to play
successful 145 blues shuffles in any
key. Let me show you. Let's take for
example the key of A. So, if we were to
apply this twoot note blues hack, right?
We would of course need to cover the A
chord, right? Or an A7. So, what we're
going to be doing is we're going to be
taking these two notes I'm talking
about, which in the key of A happen to
be these two right here, [music]
which is the fifth fret on the D string
and then sixth fret on the G string.
[music]
So, these two notes, which funnily
enough are not the note A, right, which
would be this note. If we were to play
it, you know, an octave up, [music] it's
actually these notes. So, this is how
they sound when I have an A droning over
them. [music]
pretty much completing an A7 chord,
right? Or an A dominant chord, but we're
really only focusing on these two notes.
[music]
So, check this out. Usually, when you're
in a band situation as a guitar player,
we tend to do like we'll play like full
bar chords or something like [music]
stuff like that, you know? But really,
depending on the situation you're in,
like let's say if you're in a band that,
you know, of course, has a rhythm
section, right? You got drums, bass,
maybe you have keys, right? Maybe you
have a harmonica player, maybe you have
a horn section. You know, whoever likes
to show up at the blues jams, you know,
it's different every time, but generally
as guitar players, there's a certain
pocket that we need to sit in a band mix
that these two notes cover perfectly.
So, let's say, for example, in a simple
blues shuffle, let's say the bass player
is holding it down with a nice like uh,
you know, kind of swingy like
and then meanwhile the keyboard player
is doing something like [music]
something like that, right? You know,
just imagine like a Hammond organ
playing some bluesy licks like that,
right? what your job as a guitar player
to be to make sure you're sitting in the
right place and not stepping on anyone's
toes is more or less this. [music]
That's all you would need to play to get
the job done. Right? Now, this again is
is particularly important when you're
talking about playing in a combo, right,
with a whole band. Now, this works
perfectly too if you're just jamming
with just one person, too. You know,
again, because these two notes, they
cover all the ground that we need. So,
what are these two notes? These two
notes happen to be the flat 7 and the
third, the major third or we're talking
about an A chord, right?
You don't have to know exactly how I
come to that conclusion on what those
scale degrees are. Just know that the
two notes we're talking about, right,
for over the chord are the flat 7 and
the major third, right? [music]
So, we we've got that covered for the
one chord, right?
[music]
So if we were to do something like
just playing those notes just like that,
[music]
you know, you can imagine someone would
be able to to easily solo over just that
little little groove you're doing. Now
what happens when we got to move to the
four chord, right? So if we're in the
key of A, our four is going to be D.
[music]
But instead of playing a full chord or a
bar chord or anything like that, we're
going to use this twoot note hack here.
Here's the best part. We're going to
take this, right? Remember, fifth fret
and sixth fret on the D and G strings.
We're going to take this shape here,
[music]
and we're just going to flatten it.
We're going to move both notes down a
single fret each.
Now, what happens when we get here?
We're actually going to be covering the
third and the flat 7 for the four chord.
But the cool thing is they're actually
the the order is inverted. So it's third
flat 7 now and this being the root.
[music] So root 3r flat 7.
Whereas over the one chord we had root
flat 7 third. So it's still the two
notes we needed, right? Flat 7 third 3r
3 third flat [music] 7. So it's still
it's different order but still the right
notes that we need. That's the cool
thing about this particular shape. All
we're doing, by the way, you can use
your third finger if you want to or your
second finger. It doesn't really matter.
With this shape, you're moving it down
one fret. You're trying to go from the
one to the four chord to be like this.
[music]
See how just with those two notes, you
can almost hear the movement of the
chords, right? without any kind of, you
know, without me having to do anything
else, right? If I were to apply, you
know, the bass notes, it'd be like this,
[music]
right? And of course, it would kind of
add some more context and it make more
sense. But we really don't even need to
do that, [music]
right? And I'm just applying a simple
groove, just little little stabs, right?
[music]
Because something like that would be
perfect, especially when you have like a
really active moving baseline like I
demonstrated earlier. Something like
[music]
something like that. Right? So something
like this would be perfect under that.
[music]
Right? So you get the idea. Now we also
have we have one more chord. Right?
Typical three chord blues in a 12 bar.
Right? We got 1 145. We did the one
chord, the four chord. Now we got the
five chord. Now here's the best part,
right? We're we're still staying within
this neighborhood, keeping this shape
together. All we're having to do to hit
that five chord is moving it up a fret
from the one chord. Right? So we have
four down here, [music]
one, and then up one fret for five.
Right? So the five chord in a would be
E. Right? So we have the root. If if
we're actually forming out that chord,
we have the root third [music]
flat 7.
There's our E dominant, right? Our E
dominant or E7 triad there.
[music]
But if I were to remove the the the bass
notes, right, the root notes, we just
have [music]
so it works. So if we were to use this
in context, you know,
[music]
[music] you can add little
embellishments here and there, you know,
right then.
[music]
And right there, just by using those two
notes, that flat seven and that third,
right? And and as the order uh changes,
right, when you change the chords,
you're still hanging on those same exact
notes. You've got yourself an entire 12
bar blues, three chords, right? 1, four,
and five. And you really don't need to
do anything else. Now, let's say you
want to adapt this to a new key. Let's
say you want to do, I don't know, G,
right? So, you'd want to start with
finding the root note, right? you kind
this is kind of using the fretboard
conveyor belt method, right? Starting
with using the root note on the low E
string. So we know G is the third fret
on the low E string, right? So now that
we've got we've established that this is
going to be our neighborhood for all the
for these two note hack here. So we're
going to start with our first chord,
[music]
right? So it literally sits directly
below where the root note is. So that
flat 7 and that third are going to be on
the third fret of D and then the fourth
fret of G. [music]
So that's our one chord. So if we were
to go through, you know, like the chord
changes,
[music]
right?
And if let's say we wanted to move it to
the key of let's say C sharp, right?
That would be here. The C# sharp on the
low E string is on the ninth fret here,
right? So we know that's where the root
note is. So we just drop that that two
note hack, right? Our little two note
shape, which is going to be uh the flat
7 is here on the ninth fret of the D
string. 10th fret on G is going to be
the third. And then same same deal.
[music]
Literally any key you can adapt this to.
If you want to do E, I recommend doing
it in a higher octave, right? So you're
going to be going a little bit up here
on the fretboard, but finding E, right?
Instead of open E, you'd find the 12th
fret E, right? It's the same thing,
[music]
you know? So, it literally applies to
any key. All you have to do is just
fretboard conveyor belt it to whatever
location you need to to adapt to the
right key. And voila, you are now
playing the blues in whatever key that
you find yourself in. So, there it is.
Your twoot note blues hack that's going
to allow you to jam the blues in any
key, anytime, anywhere. And you're going
to start coming off like a seasoned
blues pro when you jam with anybody. And
speaking of jamming, I still owe you
that free gift. Here it is.
It's a free blues solo heat map. So,
today we went over a very powerful hack
to allow you to play blues rhythm guitar
at any key anywhere on the fretboard,
but this is going to allow you to play
some ripping red-hot blues solos all
over the fretboard as well. So, you
definitely want to complement that with
what you just learned today. So, be sure
to click here to claim your copy or
check the link in the description box.
Well, that about does it for this video.
I want to thank you for hanging out with
me today. I hope you've enjoyed this
lesson as much as I've enjoyed bringing
it to you. I'm Eddie with Guitar
Mastering Method and I look forward to
seeing you in the next lesson. [music]